so let's follow up a little bit on the
Michael Cohen story yesterday I reported
to you about this just massive massive
story of how Michael Cohen Trump's
personal attorney received over a
million dollars in payments through a
shell company that we specifically know
of allegedly more than four million
dollars in total the details of which we
don't yet fully know 200k from AT&T that
we now learned was probably closer to
six hundred thousand four hundred
thousand from Novartis which Novartis
has now admitted was actually 1.2
million dollars supposedly five hundred
thousand from a Russian oligarch tied to
Vladimir Putin this is a story about
criminality it's a story about swamp
filling it's a story related to the
molar investigation and to Trump and
Cohen and cronyism and corruption it's
one of the biggest stories in a while
and Fox News during the three-hour
period falling following these
revelations simply didn't cover it
Tucker Carlson for example during
primetime had plenty of time to talk
about an outrageous mural showing Donald
Trump on a spear plenty of time for that
Michael a vanadis tweet about this was
mentioned on Bret Bayers show right
before 7:00 p.m. Eastern it was
dismissed by a Republican lobbyist as
nonsense I'll play that clip for you a
little bit later and then Michael
Cohen's name was not mentioned again
until after 11:00 p.m. Eastern Time then
the following morning same thing
mentioned in passing on Fox and Friends
no real coverage five total minutes were
spent on the Michael Cohen revelations
in the something like 15 hours following
the revelations of the story and this is
part of Fox News protecting Trump and it
leads to something I've called
informational incongruity before we've
talked about this now a couple times on
the show if we all agree on what the
important issues are we can debate the
issue if we all at least know what
issues are we can debate their
importance if we don't even know what's
going on at the most fundamental levels
of government and grow government
cronies we have no real ability to
actually debate and the Fox News
audience would have no idea what's going
on with Michael Cohen and thus it
wouldn't even figure into their
calculation about how serious these
allegations
our which is really great for Donald
Trump and the sort of as a really funny
sidebar the moment this came up on Brett
Bayers show right so at 7:00 p.m. the
primetime blackout started on Fox News
just before 7:00 p.m. on Brett Bay or 6
p.m. show this is briefly mentioned and
Republican lobbyist match slap happened
to be on Brett Bayers show at the time
and he said don't worry about this
Michael Cohen stuff it doesn't prove
that there's any Russian collusion a
total red herring right here's the clip
from Fox News do another thing just
happened before we went on air Matt
Michael avenatti the attorney for stormy
Daniels tweets out after significant
investigation we've discovered that mr.
Trump's attorney mr. Cohen received
approximately $500,000 in the months
after the election from a company
controlled by a Russian oligarch with
close ties to mr. Putin these monies may
have reimbursed the 130,000 payment to
stormy Daniels we've reached out to
Michael Cohen and his attorney no
response yet multiple different agencies
reporting about this this payment what
about this this is the I think why the
American people get frustrated I don't
know if mr. avenatti is stormy Daniels
lawyer or if he's the lawyer for hashtag
resistance to try to do everything he
can to weaken the president I think this
is like several bank shots I guess to
show that there's some kind of collusion
with Russia and I think the American
people are fair and if there is no
proven collusion with Russia that
impacted the election I think they are
tired of all the theatrics with this
investigation show us what you have give
us the facts and let's move on as a
country and obviously nothing coming
from the Muller team as of yet we'll
continue to follow up on that fine of
$1,000.00 just the best right so first
this guy says listen whether michael
cohen received millions of dollars from
people trying to buy influence with
donald trump it doesn't prove prove that
there was russian collusion well who's
saying that those two things are
directly linked other than the fact that
there was a Russian oligarch allegedly
involved but this is not actually about
Russian collusion we're talking about
possible bribes here it is a completely
different story although still you don't
ever get that far from Russia there
seemed to always be Russians involved
but also notice the words that
clap used he said unless we see proof of
Russian collusion that influenced the
results of the election that is another
goalposts move because before it was
there was no Russian collusion then it
became if there was collusion then it
wouldn't have been illegal and now
unless we prove that the election
results were actually flipped by that
Russian collusion then nobody should
care about this is something that you
will see happen very very often it is
goal posts moving and it is also a
distraction and the bigger story now
then that they're going to forever move
the goalposts is that this is something
above and beyond what we even conceived
of when this entire thing started you
weren't gonna hear about it on Fox News
though they were definitely not going to
tell you about what was going on I
understand those people who say that we
should focus more on things like health
care and jobs and maybe less on Russia
or stormy Daniels and all that stuff
point taken but when you have a 24/7
news show and this is the top story at
the time you can't explain away a four
hour blackout on a major channel and
well you can explain it away as this is
a concerted effort to protect the
president right I mean the the on what
the explanations are really bad and
there's no benign way to explain it away
for sure tonight on Hannity why is that
the fact that Michael Cohen was being
paid by AT&T actually about killer his
uranium one deal very very big breaking
story tonight on Hannity send me your
thoughts about the blackout send me your
thoughts about what's going on with
Michael Cohen I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program is made
possible in part by fruit or fruit or is
a social forecasting game where players
come together and compete with each
other to predict future events you open
up the game on your phone or web browser
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you wager on predictions about
real world events using futures in game
fake currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability
I'm even on futur you can find my
account and follow me by clicking the
link in the description if you're
watching this on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at fruit or comm
and start making your forecasts on
political topics and tons of other
topics totally free available on both
Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers that is fut you you are calm